oh I don't know they call them extremist
and I don't know I'd be like Colin wash
you know George Washington extreme
well a lot of people say he's too
extreme and like he shut down the
government you have to do things like
that to make a point to Washington to
show Washington that we need change they
act as if he's an establishment she's
clearly not or he's just a neocon or
he's just going to carry on like the
third term of the Bush presidency or
something like that it's absurd I'm
tired of hearing him called radical I
don't believe what he believes his
radical probably the worst I've heard is
people saying talking about his
Christian faith fan it's a bad thing but
I don't think it is
I've heard a lot that he's not eligible
birther stuff it's just a distraction
from the issues his citizenship I don't
think that's an issue I guess I should
probably read the mailings that come in
the mail that are against him since they
go in the garbage because I just know it
it's false I'm tired of hearing that you
can't beat Hillary and we need somebody
that can beat Hillary we can't afford
another four years of what we have right
now
you